[Música]
i
[Aplausos]
olá bom dia
queremos agradecer o convite para estar
nesta quinta mas é uma rotação não posso
até discreto mas por apresentar já só as
fiesta sinal e esta é a joana está o
nosso senhor
nós temos um pereira rosa estar aqui foi
dito nós estamos habituados a preparar
um palco com outras pessoas e não
faltará o gt a falar neste momento nossa
preocupação devia ser assim no tempo
andantes
estamos aqui para procurar um caminho da
nossa história
nós não somos opas chamamos assim foi
literalmente isso cris anos conseguimos
juntar ou pós vamos lá
é uma opção muito equipe karnak o norte
é então queremos contar um carinho nossa
história se passa há cinco anos atrás
estávamos nessa galáxia a fazer a
decoração e não é importante estarmos
aqui que mora naquela altura eu nunca me
passaria pela cabeça a tudo começou
nunca vi um ano antes de este ter ex nós
tínhamos terminado a faculdade
conhecemos lá ficamos amigas e quando
foi pular terminou somente em 2010 no
que eu na crise se fazer sentida as
pessoas emigrarem havia muito para si
mesmo e nós mandamos reclamando do
esporte falas e nem sequer respostas
temos e os postos diminuíram
acho que nós criamos am então era o
clima ideal
vamos avançar nós sabemos que temos que
fazer a nossa própria emoção eu porque
vamos lá a ver as nossas antenas e não
querem mais do que fazer um pouso no
facebook quer dizer que ela está muito
mal e vavá a e jantar nos mas como
qualquer negócio
o projeto foi iniciado precisa do
investimento
nós cumprimos acabar a faculdade a fim
de juntar as nossas poupanças todas
fizemos muitas plantas e vou comprar
este facto nós não tínhamos dinheiro
para muito mais queremos acabar o curso
estamos mesmo sem dinheiro imagina
quando precisamos mesmo é de ver este
fase do metro que anunciamos
literalmente nos podemos encontrar os
três todos os dias pra começarmos a
alguma coisa então a primeira nós temos
três coisas fundamentais que era muito
tempo livre porque estamos empregadas
temos muita vontade de fazer alguma
coisa criar uma coisa nem que fossem
contamos as pedras nem que fosse para
não ficarmos parados e teremos nós
precisamos pasto métricas deixávamos ela
fosse lá encantarmos pá como as
primeiras pessoas com quem nós porque
temos esta é a nossa vontade é que os
nossos pessoas já focou apenas acaba
achamos que as pessoas que tinham mais
opiniões podem estar e mais feedback e
acharam que devemos avançar vários nosso
daremos apoio e isso deu a oportunidade
nós fazemos há um ano venho conversando
na faculdade porque eu tinha já essa
essa vontade mas nunca tinha conseguido
pôr em prática então como nós tínhamos o
crime fazer os projetos nós acabamos por
ser o projeto piloto e foi ótimo porque
conseguimos ter uma van com um espaço
usar o método gratuitamente só temos que
em troca eu trabalhava popular eu se
fosse necessário
então começa nessa nós tivemos a
felicidade de nos cumprimentarmos
enquanto equipa nos perguntarmos
enquanto designers e também para
começarmos já conhece nossas primeiras
companhias brasileiras a e também
é conseguir os primeiros clientes a no
fundo este gasto médio por seria
insignificante por cia um impedimento
tão pequeno mas foi a única coisa que
foi preciso fazer nos pára pra começar
já foram as idéias em prática
começamos com até o trabalho mais típico
do isae não é no início começamos a
fazer o que os katharsis wap push isso
mas não dei a primeira casa possamos num
centro comercial muito conhecido mas na
comunidade artística do porto ou centro
comercial bombarda e gian cruzou se
connosco e nós estávamos com uma peça em
papel e aula desafios a fazer a
decoração de uma montra que muitas vezes
está lá está vazia então e iria ver com
inaugurações simultâneas e era uma boa
oportunidade na altura de nos dar já
conhecerá as pessoas procuram junto e
rufino ninguém me conhecia e então
pronto iremos fazer um manifesto como
nós tínhamos dito nós gostamos das
nossas poupanças todas no paço com um
metro por isso não tenhamos dinheiro pra
fazer grande impressões ao acabamento
essa manga só tenhamos nós e as nossas
mãos para fazer alguma coisa por isso
tivemos a conseguimos reunir o maior
número maior número de caixas de cartão
porque nós temos que gostamos da
modalidade e explorará a acessibilidade
do papel e achamos que seria um bom
desafio fazer esta montra esse manifesto
com isto o feedback das pessoas que vão
começaram a aparecer alguns álbuns tudo
100 em cartão e então isso o governo
está a fazer nosso primeiro trabalho
encomendado com cartão e papel que foi o
palco do telex ivo é que o filme entrou
nesse palco nós conhecemos 11 jogadores
que foi o caso de coisa que eu tinha eu
tenho uma agência muito conhecida a
portuguesa que é evidente e os desafios
neste momento a fazer chama-se data em
questão a escala real enquanto em quatro
semanas depois nós tinha nós tínhamos
isto foi um desafio enorme e foi aí que
nós encontramos aquilo que
influenciou outros atores design ea
nossa imagem marca as pessoas começaram
a conhecer nos muito pelo cartão em tudo
e por isso as meninas que jogaram
naquilo que supostamente é o lixo e que
as pessoas não dava muito valor e
construímos alguma coisa com isso os
clientes também começou a ser uma
mais-valia nós começamos a fazer as
coisas com o cartão eo coração para
eventos provavelmente os eventos moravam
23 dias e não precisavam dar fosse muito
duradoura e então também precisavam
qualquer coisa que fosse barato e tem um
cartão com um trouxe uma opção muito bom
para isso e além do mais era um material
sustentava e acaba por ser um símbolo a
utilizar depois voltar já foi utilizado
era um ciclo sustentável
fomos aprimorando as nossas técnicas
fomos cada vez mais rápido é construir
as coisas e e desenvolverá as peças e e
também fomos melhorando a forma como nós
fazemos nós nunca tínhamos trabalhado
com programas 3d e ao longo dos nossos
trabalhos começamos a aprender por nós
próprios e com gestos em tudo que
estamos a primeira planificados projetos
em 3d e depois construiu isso ajudou nos
avisou e valos nos passa e tudo mais
também estaremos muito papel que dar
muita muita mais riqueza textura e
decotes e promo norte outras portas
foram se abrindo e fomos fazendo o
paralelo vivendi também a decoração do
dos cenários para a televisão e para
para anunciantes e também é só são
sempre uma experiência assim um carrinho
de frente assim como para pressões que
também o material o papel por ser uma
terra tão portátil é fácil nós
conseguimos construir qualquer coisa
além do mais fomos ram
vamos fazer um projeto lá fora e as
pessoas lá no estrangeiro começaram a
conhecer nosso trabalho e isso dá nos a
oportunidade incrível não é
a ver com o nosso trabalho lá consegue
chegar lá fora no vovô vamos logo quero
vender projetos
foi muito especial para nós não só por
suas dimensões que eu tinha mas também
sua prova de força que foi pra nós é
isto evento chama todo fofo
em todos os anos em um estudante todo
mundo pára e desafios a não tema da
segurança alimentar porque acredita se
que em 2050 no gráfico é alimentação
para toda a população humana
então eu sorrio nem estudante e todos
achavam que escolher as minhas ideias
para resolver esse problema e juntou se
emocionar qualquer do mundo para
partilhar e para para se conhecerem por
agir enquanto comunidade por um melhor e
nós a o ano passado foi em lisboa foi
esta foi aqui no começo biato que é um
evento é um espaço incrível com maior
casas lindas mãos natural impressionante
e é também muito muito grandes ou seja
muito ângulo
o que causa um problema mas conhece
esses eventos mais porque tem muita
gente mas é preciso também estará longe
então nós teremos logo no início que
definir de um aterro de ter as
conferências do outro lado temos que
andar um espaço networking niza do relax
então nós depois de visitar mas o
convento havíamos proposto é para
começar o projeto fizemos o projeto em
3d pensarmos a preparar tudo em
catanduva a fazer os primeiros recordes
porque como e ele tem pouco tempo para a
montagem
queremos preparar tudo antes tínhamos de
quatro dias do evento antes os senhores
que estavam a montar as estruturas
tínhamos pedindo para parar a festas
acho que sei pra esse projeto acabaram
das futuras não ficamos
o que é isto isto é muito muito alto nós
não somos três mil vagas número é 4
temos uma ajudante
como é que nós vamos chegar lá se marque
um livro não pode ser não há qualquer
coisa que está errada aqui mas a verdade
é que tava tudo exatamente como tínhamos
planeado só que eram os 4.000 do norte
anunciar por eles de dois três quatro
cinco metros de altura foi um desafio
incrível e toda a gente já estava a
começar a duvidar de nós porque como é
que não consigo fazer isso à própria
cliente deus pra nós se tiverem que
implicará uma coisa de quem não há
problema não vamos deixar como está você
mas nós não quisemos existia criamos
criamos ferramentas como o evento fosse
exatamente aquilo que sonhamos e então
não dormimos passarmos horas para o
estado ajuda horas também em pôr alegria
com aquela que eu não vejo falta de sono
mas acabámos por conseguir acabámos por
conseguir montar tudo pequenos a montar
e fazer tudo e tivemos a oportunidade de
ver a reação das pessoas a entrar no no
inverno e essa é para nós a maior
recompensa do nosso trabalho é podermos
estar no sítio no local e conseguimos
ver o que as pessoas estão a perceber o
que é que eu estou a sentir e ver nos
pessoas super surpreendendo a tirar
fotografias explanam já é é
incrivelmente recompensador e esta esta
história é no fundo empatada entre 200 e
nós também não somos só deve sair antes
nós chegamos fomos obrigados a ser um
cara em tudo fundo somos a empreendedora
estamos somos contadores estão bonitas
são estrelas
vai treinar este propósito enquanto isso
assim o tc e e isto acontece porque
porque acreditamos nesta unidade nós que
estamos às vezes dá grandes e de certa
forma a crise não não duas coisas mas
não com a troika nem com os orçamentos
de estado
agradecemos por que está assim com seis
anos atrás tivesse tudo ok nós a
história estava nos nossos empregos
novas cinco passado foi suco é ver o que
se passa o que passa no mundo e meia
disse não estamos aqui hoje ms palco é
tentar mostrar aquilo que nós realmente
estamos fazer e aquilo que achamos que
fazemos de melhor disco em frança
no fundo eu acho que estávamos também
transmitir a ideia que as crises podem
ser qualquer um não precisa ser eu a
financeiras podem ser crianças pessoais
pode ser uma dor de barriga
tem que tem aquelas funções para casa
cada título um problema e para ea vida
de cada pessoa não queremos estar a
dizer que a solução para tudo para todos
os tipos de crise é um só uma empresa
começar a fazer coisas cartão não o que
achamos é que temos é que o seguro com
esse ano é de fazer tem que fazer aquilo
que nós realmente tínhamos aquilo que
gostamos de fazer o melhor por isso no
fundo temos que deixar a porta aberta
como é um tema instigante e com certeza
que vai entrar muita comentar porque
pois acho que não teremos tão boas mas
já estamos a ver testemunhado por ser
coisas que realmente nos aquecem alma e
sabão em algum momento acharem que as
coisas são impossíveis de fazer lembra
gostava de fumar sem nós três mil mudas
começar um negócio com cachês carta
sobre a
[Aplausos]
[Música]